but first we join now from central
London by the health secretary in that
Hancock the man who's been at the heart
of the government's response to the
pandemic so let's get straight to that
Hancock shall we now thank you very much
for being on the program lots of
questions that our viewers want to know
the answers to you this morning you've
said today in The Sunday Telegraph that
our generation has never been tested
like this and the you came has pulled
together like it did during the Second
World War
is this a crisis like we've never seen
since World War two I think it is one of
the biggest challenges that we've faced
for a generation we've been through
worse as a country of course we have but
it is a very significant challenge you
know the the measures that we're that
we're taking the measures that we're
looking at taking are very very
significant and they will they will
disrupt the ordinary lives of almost
everybody in the country in order to
tackle this virus and I think it is a
big challenge as the country you know
this is a national effort of course we
in government have got a huge weight of
responsibility to get the response right
but and the NHS has got an extraordinary
extraordinary time ahead of it and I'm
sure that it will rise to that challenge
but it won't be easy but every single
person can act and I was on your program
a couple of weeks ago and saying
everyone can act by washing their hands
we'll take the right action at the right
time nationally and we will be asking
people to do to do more than that in
order to prevent the spread of this
disease
you know our objective is to protect
life and that's why we're going to be
taking some of the measures that were
that we're taking all set out in the
action plan a couple of weeks ago but
the time is coming and you say that the
time is coming certainly even in that
space of just a couple of weeks it does
feel as this the situation we're in
today has rapidly changed from you know
just singing happy birthday while
washing your hands important though that
is what exactly are you asking people to
do then you're saying that you're gonna
be stepping up the response
well don't forget that washing your
hands is still the single most important
thing that anybody could do everybody
should be washing their hands more often
that stops their slows the spread it
kills the virus and it's incredibly
important to wash your hands while
singing happy birthday so let's not
forget that that that is absolutely
central but we also need to take steps
to protect the vulnerable and we set out
in the plan how we would be prepared to
do that and to advise the elderly and
the vulnerable who are most at risk from
this virus too to protect themselves to
shield themselves by self isolating and
we'll be setting out and when that's
necessary we don't want to do that too
soon because if we do it's clearly you
know not an easy thing for people to do
it's not an easy thing for people to
sustain but the critical thing is we
need to be ready and we everybody as a
community needs to be ready to support
the people who are being shielded for
their own protection the elderly and the
vulnerable I'm keen to talk more about
the shielding and because there'll be
lots of people watching will be wanting
to know exactly what this means in
practice so if there are reports that
the government is going to be asking
people over the age of 70 to self
isolate to stay at home for up to four
months
is that right well the answers that is
not yet and the reason that we are not
saying that yet it's just because this
length of time that people would have to
take that action to protect itself is
very long and that is in the plan yes
it's clearly in the action plan the
thing that we're saying today is that we
need a national effort also to help
prepare the NHS so we've been working to
buy as many ventilators as we can
because that's one of the critical
things that's needed for people who are
ill I mean today the Prime Minister is
I'm keen to talk about that but just be
crystal clear on the elderly the
government will be asking there over 70s
to self isolate potentially for a period
of months
some point in the future that is in the
action plan yes and we'll be setting it
out with more detail when that's the
right it's the right time to do so
because we absolutely appreciate that it
is that is a very big ask of the elderly
and the vulnerable and it's for their
own self-protection are we talking about
days weeks away how long are we talking
well certainly in the in the coming
weeks absolutely okay thank you now I'm
keen as well to talk about what you were
just saying they're about effectively
asking British manufacturers to be put
on a war footing if you like to turn
their production lines over to start
producing these ventilators so how many
ventilators do we have and how many do
we need well we have a round we start
with around 5,000 ventilators we think
we need many times more than that and
we're set we're saying that if you
produce a ventilator then we will buy it
no number is too high and and we we're
working with companies we've been
working with them for some time but to
buy ventilators that are available but
also to switch over production to
ventilators and other critical equipment
like personal protection equipment for
instance but the ventilators are the big
thing they are you know they're they're
built that they're relatively
complicated pieces of kit I couldn't
make one but they're not so complicated
that them that the advanced
manufacturing that this country is so
good at now can't be able to turn its
production lines over to we've been
talking to a whole host of companies
about it and the Prime Minister's
hosting a conference call today with
them to to say very clearly to the
nation's manufacturers ventilators are
the thing that we are going to need and
and frankly right across the world the
the demand for them is incredibly high
so it is not possible to produce too
many so anybody who can
should turn their production and their
engineering minds over to the production
of ventilators
so we have 5000 ventilators other
countries have many times more can you
guarantee that everybody who needs the
ventilator will get one well that is
absolutely the task to reduce the spread
of this virus and to build up the
capacity in the NHS at the same time
it's not only the physical machines we
need we also need the trained people to
use them and we're currently retraining
doctors into the use of ventilators
because we are going to have to that's
that's the Frank truth we don't have
enough what we need we need more
absolutely I mean if we wouldn't be
putting out this call if if this wasn't
the the core piece of equipment that we
need to help people through this virus
yeah as health secretary my number one
task is to protect lives and we do that
by protecting the vulnerable and
protecting the NHS and the thing that
the NHS needs now more than anything is
more ventilators we've been buying as
many as we can but we need to produce
more - because it's clear that what we
need more here - so does everybody else
across the world so we can't guarantee
can we that everyone who needs a
ventilator will get one well you've
heard me say many times that we don't
make guarantees in healthcare and this
is this virus is clearly a huge
challenge and we're learning about it
every day so I don't make guarantees
like that what I will guarantee is we
will do everything we possibly can to
protect life and to keep people safe but
this is a very very significant
challenge and you know they've seen in
some other countries around the world
where it hasn't gone well and thankfully
so far since the early days of the virus
the rate of increase here in the UK is
lower than other European countries
that's because the brilliant work of
public health England and their contact
tracing it's also because we've been
doing more testing than almost any other
country in the world outside of China
and South Korea literally
the major epicenters and that testing
capacity is expanding rapidly as well in
fact there's a there's another big
industrial challenge which we're working
on with industry which is to have to get
more tests and in particular a test that
can be done by the bedside rather than a
test that has to go to the lab everybody
around the world is is crying out for
that and we've been working for several
months now with testing companies to get
that testing capability so the response
thus far has been an incredible amount
of work but has has helped to slow the
spread but clearly this virus is a very
very significant problem and so we are
we're throwing everything at it and
there's talk about the government trying
to pass emergency powers and next week
in Parliament so it can do more for
example allowing police to detain
infective people forcing schools and
nurseries to stay open
what are those emergency powers going to
be yes we're going to set out the
emergency powers on a Tuesday and
publish the bill on Thursday I've been
talking to John Ashworth the shadow
health secretary who thinks on the
program shortly about what's in them
this is a this is a cross-party approach
he's made some suggestions of other
things that should be in there which
we've included and and we we didn't
include a whole a broad range of of
actions and all about preparing Britain
and making sure the way that we're ready
should we need to be is the government
going to be banning gatherings of over
500 people well clearly as we set out in
the action plan two weeks ago we are
absolutely ready to do that as necessary
and there's a whole host of further
steps well will we've got a cobra
meeting tomorrow we will take these
decisions at the right time but I'm
absolutely prepared to take actions like
that if that's what's necessary we've
already seen many sporting events for
instance being can't
and lots of these big gatherings being
being canceled the thing that really
matters in terms of slowing the spread
the biggest things I'll are washing your
hands if you're ill at all
cough or high temperature then you
should stay at home for seven days that
is absolutely critical and then the the
next steps like the sort of the
isolation for vulnerable people in older
people that we talked about at the start
these are the really big things that
that slow the spread and save the lives
and and and things like the mass
gatherings actually you know it it
doesn't really matter how big the
gathering is what matters is making sure
that people who have the illness aren't
spreading it and stay home another thing
that many people worried about is the
provision of food and we've all seen
those empty supermarket shelves with yes
seen delays to online shopping retailers
have gotten a letter basically saying
that buying more than is needed can
sometimes mean others will be left
without I mean this is quite alarming
yes are you worried that the food supply
might be at risk No so one of the things
that we are confident about is that the
food supply that will continue now well
that is that it we're confident about it
what I what I can guarantee is that will
work with the supermarket's to make sure
that people get enough and and that you
know that the I understand why people
might be what might be stocking up but
it is people have got to behave
responsibly I suppose you're right -
well I think the supermarkets are great
to write the letter calling on people to
bear to be responsible and to consider
the impact that their stocking up might
have on others and and we've coursed
stand ready to take further measures if
that's necessary now I just want to talk
a little bit about the government's
response to this because lots of our
viewers will be seeing schools closing
missing shops and pubs closing in France
that we've seen the US imposing travel
bans and we're not doing this and
they'll be thinking why is the UK
government so sure that we're right here
and all the other countries are wrong
well each country is taking measures
according to their own circumstances
we're similar to many countries for
instance we're very similar to the
approach being taken in Germany and
we're and Australia and others it's
about making sure you do the right thing
at the right time we're prepared to take
if we need to all the sorts of measures
that you discuss but we will do it based
on the science and of course there's a
lively debate about what's the best
course of action and the scientific
evidence is absolutely critical in
underpinning our response you know we
want to have the very best response in
the world thankfully so far we have
managed to keep the growth of this virus
here slower than in other European
countries but we will absolutely take
the measures that we that that we think
are needed at the right time based on
the best scientific advice you say that
it's based on the same built on the best
scientific eyes so why don't you
transparently publish that advice and
the government's modelling because in a
minute we don't know how many people are
in hospital or in critical care we don't
know that the information about how many
people are picking up the virus in the
UK rather wound abroad we don't fully
understand the science behind your
approach we've been talking about herd
immunity for a week and today you say
that's not part of the strategy if
you're so convinced that this is
following the science
why don't you publish it so that people
can take it on their own knowledge
rather than just on trust yes we're
going to do that in the in the coming
days I think that's really important I
agree with you and the the overall
already well because our scientists are
extremely busy and we and we've working
incredibly hard so but we'll do that in
the next in the next couple of days the
overall plan is based on the science and
based on transparency again our response
is one of the most transparent in the
we published the plan right at the start
to explain the sorts of actions we might
have to take and I remember when we
published it and when I talked about on
this program there was quite a lot of
surprise that explained we could do
these measures but we won't do them now
in terms of the number of people
affected and we are as we are fully
transparent about that and in fact now
have a website where you can interrogate
all of that data because the best
science is done in the open so that
people can challenge and and ask
questions and make suggestions you know
I'd rather have a hundred suggestions
even if only one of them is something
new that we that we hadn't thought of
the the goal here is to get the very
best response for the UK and you know
though that the the challenge and the
debate in public I think is a good thing
to try to get the very best response
after all this is something that the
whole country needs to need to do
because the whole country is going to
have to go through this and it is being
up for debate now your approach is being
challenged when we've had this letter
from hundreds of scientists claiming the
government is risking many more lives
than necessary by not implementing
immediate social distancing measures
Richard Horton the editor of the Lancer
for example the medical journal saying
the UK government Matt Hancock and Boris
Johnson claim they're following the
science but that is not true the
evidence is clear we need urgent
implementation of social distancing and
closure policies the government is
playing roulette with a Coppa public
this is a major error are you playing
roulette
no obviously and you've got the I'm not
going to go into responding to that that
particular accusation what we'll do is
listen to all of the credible scientists
and we'll look at all of the evidence
and we'll listen to also all of the all
the politicians who are making points
about the judgments that you that we
make but what we will not do is deviate
from having a plan that is based on the
very best scientific advice and and
that's important I saw the letter the
letter was saying that a goal of herd
immunity is is the wrong thing to do and
herd immunity is not our is not a our
goal or policy it's a scientific concept
our policy is to protect lives and to
beat this virus okay
Matthew Hancock thank you very much
Diploma in the program today explaining
the government's response to coronavirus
much appreciated good to be with you